that's not the clip of you on The Ellen
Show you're a fan of Justin Bieber's and
he just started following you on today
right
he just started following you his
buddy's been on yeah his butt has been
on that seat before but you will meet
did you meet the Biebs did he meet
Justin Bieber not me Justin Bieber what
the hell dude man could we keep playing
with me cuz I'm there like so you
shouldn't I blanket your love for the
Biebs starts you know what it started
when I was like 12 I believe and that
was like right before he retired where
did you post hers in your room I did
yeah McVeigh gasps you have so many
celebrity fans Julia Roberts Halley
Bieber just posted about you is anyone
sliding into those DMS yet
I mean Bieber did What did he say that
the thing that he actually no the first
thing he sent was a screenshot of a DM I
sent him in 2014 you stopped so he
remembered from 23 didn't remember it
but you know how when you follow
somebody yeah you can see everything
they've DM do in the past right so when
he started following you he got the
notifications yeah it like felt good and
I felt bad at the same thing yeah but it
was amazing he's he's so sweet like I
feel I just honestly I feel for him man
he's he's gone through hot dude he said
he has an album coming out and I feel
like we should get the Billy Eilish
feature on that album so how do did you
guys talk about that Billy Eilers
proving she's a true believer at the
opening of her la pop-up the Billy
Eilish experience by Spotify this is
crazy there's a Tonka statue of me with
it celebrates the release of her first
full-length album which is out now I
mean it's funny because sometimes you
dream about something and you might
write it down you might tell people and
be like this is what I want you know in
my wildest dream and then I did that and
here is which is like it's so
because yesterday I came by for the
first time to like to see everything in
person and it just was like everything
that I've wanted it to be for this whole
time it's literally like I stepped into
my own brain like I mean you're breaking
spotify records you're breaking Apple
music records this album is supposed to
sell I think over 300,000 copies are you
ready for the next level of superstardom
no no I think I am honestly no I think I
I feel like I feel like I am feel like
it always happens a little bit without
really realizing it your destiny we were
with you at the I heart Awards and we
told you you know you are the second
most streamed female artist on Spotify
behind Ariana Grande and you said you're
such a big fan of her has she reached
out since you said that she hasn't but I
don't care it's okay she's doing her
thing she work him and she doesn't have
to bring it reach out yeah I love seeing
these females really taking over the
music industry how does it feel to
really be a part of that dude it's I
don't know it's honestly like just like
I'm a grind like what like that girl is
like the king she's the king for sure I
don't know it's really sick to see how
things are changing and how people are
kind of
like understanding you know that that
we're all just doing our thing you know
I'm saying what are people gonna be
surprised to learn about you when they
listen to this album for the first time
I don't know I think that there's maybe
maybe not learn about it but I think
more of just making a project that has
you know multiple multiple songs that
sound completely different from each
other but also very cohesive that was
kind of the main idea that I wanted to
kind of accomplish which was just to
have everything be like everything I
wanted everything to make sense but I
wanted it all to be completely unique on
its own you know so that if I was if
every song came out as a single they
would all do equally you know what I'm
saying where do you see your path
Colleen like what is your place in the
music industry
I'm just hoping for the best I'm like
trying to enjoy it and like not complain
because what is they're complaining
about
[Music]
[Applause]